well I think was well worth the rest of
it Nick
listen when you're talking about a
demeaning political discourse try the
British House of Commons the Prime
Minister's question time defines a
demeaning political discourse Alden felt
myself anything else is it here's some
good news because we've had with us not
some of the people from the other
universities who are not taking this
course and from from around the world
and actually the things that we're
debating here are things that they are
debating - in a very lively and
interesting way and so I think well it's
it's kind of good thing we're part of a
broader movement and actually but what I
want to do is to build very much on what
Nick has just said because I just like
to say I agree with it
right that's I just agree with it and I
want to try and take this debate to us
to the next stage because I think that
the classic divide and I found this
reading the the literature for for for
what we're going to do today the classic
divide in this debate is on the one side
religious people saying we have got the
right to enforce our view against
against you and then the secular
liberals come back and say keep your
religion out of the public realm and
it's certainly when we we analyze these
things it's not just about the
Constitution because there can be all
sorts of things that are outside the
Constitution that can still make a
difference to how religion is is viewed
I mean for example I don't know you tell
me but I think if you were an American
presidential candidate and stood up and
said I don't believe in God you probably
find I mean your campaign manager who
say I don't you should say that your
strategist your pollster would be
leaping out of their seats so you know
even if it's not
you know sometimes religion can have an
influence outside of the formal nature
but the of the debate in terms of the
Constitution but the classic divide the
religious people saying we decide that
secular liberals saying get out of the
public realm I think you can move it on
from that really because what is clear
is that as Nick has just said a
democracy a pluralist democracy or let
me say this actually a pluralist Society
because I think some of these things
apply even to non democratic societies
that are pluralist they require a common
space where difference can be
accommodated but where certain values or
norms are shared right so that the
people are expected a respective of
their religious commitment whatever
their own religion says about certain
issues nonetheless they accept they come
on a common space at a certain point and
and have to expect that common space and
the values and norms are within it so I
think most people understand that even
if they're strongly religious actually
most people not everyone but I think
most do and also and this is where I
think the thing has moved on from Rawls
time although there are people who still
come up with some quite intemperate
stuff on this but I think most people
believe also that religion can't be
excluded from the public realm in other
words there's one thing to say eyes the
religious thinker I'm going to determine
the public realm it's quite another
thing to say I simply want to be my
voice to be heard now that at its
minimal I think most people would say
nowadays well yeah of course that's true
and incidentally the fact is which I
would make for a practical point of view
if you are of religious belief in
essential religion can't be excluded it
defines you so it there is no way that
you can have a public debate in which
your religious view
is is not somehow relevant to you in
therefore relevant to the debate that is
occurring within the public realm so my
view is that this debate is not really
about liberal versus religious in the
sense of the way that say O'Donovan uses
it whereas the liberal is really a sort
of contract Arian I think is that the
right expression I mean it's to do
simply with it with a contract where is
the religious people of the people with
the values that is almost the suggestion
I I found in in in that writing it seems
to me that even if you are if you take a
non religious view of human rights
nonetheless as indeed Rawls was pointing
out behind any Constitution of right
there will lie certain ideals and those
ideals are inspired by certain values so
it isn't really true to say that the
person who's a secular liberal and says
look religion shouldn't come into this
debate is really arguing from the point
of view of saying ah I think this is
just a personal contractual issue it's
got nothing to do with the broader
society in the same way as I say that in
my view most people who are religious do
in fact accept that there is a common
space and a common Constitution written
or unwritten to which they must conform
in addition to that I think that no one
seriously thinks nowadays that society
doesn't require certain values to
underpin it I mean whether you're
religious or your secular most people
will talk about certain values that are
that lie behind whatever is the
Constitution or the legal norms to which
people are expected to to conform and
even the most non-religious politician
certainly in societies like ours
you know I think they they're not really
motivated by certain values but they see
them see themselves as representing
certain values and I think the people
are perfectly prepared mostly to see
those who are of religious belief at
least having the right participate in in
the debate and the right to say because
how can they say otherwise that their
view of a particular debate is motivated
by their religious belief so I think
it's really when we come to this
supposed very strong divide between the
secular and the religious I think most
people in a way have resolved that that
debate in their own mind I'm not saying
there aren't still people at the
extremes on either side who will say on
the religious side no I want to
determine the way the society works I'm
not prepared to accept you know my
religion impels me to act in a way
inconsistent with the Constitution
doesn't it was explained I'm sure there
are people like them but there are
people like that there are people on the
other side as you saw with the the
statement from Jacobi which is very much
you know just get out of there you
shouldn't be anywhere near this this
debate but I don't I think most people
accept the societies based on certain
values and some of those values will
derive from religion and some of those
values won't but there's a place often
that is common and overlapping I think
the more interesting questions now are
really these however in order to make a
society work effectively what is it that
is necessary for religious and
non-religious people to agree upon in
order for that society to function well
now I agree with the two principles that
that Nick is just outlined and let me
try and put this in a in my my own
way and and develop it something
somewhat I think first of all the people
who are secular need to understand also
that the religious dimension can give a
a quality of a moral nature to the
debate within society that can be
helpful and constructive and progressive
so for example I would say that over the
debates about Western policy in relation
let's say to African third world dead
the impact of those inspired by religion
had a significant impact on the
political decisions that were then taken
by leaders I would say that the g8 which
I presided over in 2005 would never have
come to its conclusions without a very
strong religious movement here back in
Europe and elsewhere in in support of
that and actually one of the big changes
in the whole issue to do with hiv/aids
and how it was treated in Africa was
when many of the Christian movements
here and decided to get over various of
the sexual issues in relation to
hiv/aids and actually embraced the
notion that it was an important part of
their religious duty in order to deal
with this that did this issue and and in
fact much of the health care that is
delivered in Africa today is delivered
by religious organizations so III think
and I would here's a very controversial
area to raise this in if you take an
issue like abortion which is very very
controversial in my society more so in
your society leave aside whether you
agree or disagree with positions of
religious people on it but I think that
it's not unhelpful
to actually have issues that are
difficult like that raised in a context
that is that is spiritually or
religiously defined now that doesn't
mean to say that you end up with the
same position of of let's say the
Catholic Church on that issue or not but
I think even secular people should
recognize that it's a debate that's
still important to have and it's a
debate that might not have taken place
in the same way unless religious people
have been prepared to put it on the
agenda now likewise I think that once
society comes to a view that view has to
be accepted right by the religious
people also but all I'm saying is there
are what I think the secular people need
to understand is that there can be a way
of raising questions is where I do agree
with her Donovan there were a way of
raising questions and um actually the
establishment of an agenda in in which
religious and spiritual thought can play
a part and can play a positive part
because otherwise some issues would not
get raised at all you know I think for
example of the work done by many church
organizations in relation to the
disabled now it's true there are many
people who are not religious at all that
raise these issues but I would have to
say in certainly in my society some of
the most extraordinary and selfless work
is done by religious organizations in
this sphere so that's the first thing
the second thing however and I think the
concomitant obligation is that people
who are religious also need to
understand that those who do not conform
to a view derived from religious belief
nonetheless of equal validity to state
that belief adhere to it and advocated
and this is where if you like the
concept of faith friendly democracy or
democracy friendly faith is is so
important you need that balance if
you're going to achieve
a proper settlement of the place of
religion within society but I think this
is not just about democracy I mean
that's I just want to make this a this
this is this amendment in a sense to our
discussion I think it is possible to
have a non democratic certainly the
sense of non democratic in a Western
sense a political system that
nonetheless is pluralist and nonetheless
has a the same relationship that I'm
describing between religious faith and
politics what is essential is is the
notion of pluralism no exact if you
don't have think that the question of
law is that and the issue blur ISM there
that that concept rooted in the society
then I think it's very difficult and so
my view is that this very what I would
call quite extreme almost a slightly
old-fashioned sense of a divide between
those people who say my religion
entitles me to enforce my view against
you and those people who say actually
you take your religious views out of
here we don't want anything to do with
that and it's not a legitimate basis
upon which you can put your case I think
that is largely people are as I say I'm
not saying it doesn't exist but I don't
think that's what most people find
difficult today most people can accept
that the religious people have a right
to express their view most religious
people have a can accept that they don't
have the right to enforce it I think the
question is though what are the
conditions that the that that give rise
to that faith friendly society and
society friendly faith and that those in
my view are as I say that the secular
needs to understand the religious can
actually enrich the social and moral
dialogue of a nation
and the religious need to understand
that those who aren't religious have
equal validity in their views the
question to my mind then becomes the
practical question of how do you best
create such societies and here's where I
think you know the political the social
and the faith conditions for such
societies are an interesting subject of
analysis and discussion because and it
may be just because of my background I
kind of think it's interesting to
analyze a question and it's even more
interesting to find an answer to the
question and so what is it that the that
gives gives rise to this because I can
describe and just have what are the
attitudes but how do you encourage those
attitudes you know how do you embed
those attitudes and here's where I think
that the the policy in it in a sense
that flows from this is as is as follows
I think to begin with there does need to
be some clear constitutional or legal
framework within which this is said and
the four principles that Nick outline
that lay behind the US Constitution
those I mean undoubtedly helped create
the sense in the u.s. today that there
is a legitimate and illegitimate way of
having the debate between religion and
politics so I think that is important I
think secondly none of this will work
without action to support it I think
this what we're talking about is radical
implications for example for our
education system and in particular the
way the religion is taught within our
education system within civic society
within the international engagement for
example the Alliance of civilizations
Khan
seht put forward by Turkey and Spain and
in in some process of development now is
is actually important in this regard and
so if we want to create that society in
which there is the balance of the proper
space for religion to make its view
clear but also that the the broader
polity that must encompass more than the
religious I think it requires that
constitutional framework
it requires policy on behalf of
government that supports such attitudes
and the third thing that it needs and
this is which touches directly on our
faith and globalization course is it
does require a certain attitude of mind
and this is where I find it it's quite
interesting just listening to Nick's
analysis of the the way that the
intellectual debate has has gone I mean
in the end what this requires isn't what
I would call an open rather than closed
attitude to both the process of
globalization and the society in which
we live and how you inculcate that
attitude has also got to be part of the
the discourse in and around this subject
because you see ultimately in order for
this balance to work in order for us to
be able to say as Nick is really
outlined for you that you should not
exclude the religious the religious has
a place and a voice but nonetheless that
is within certain rules and with certain
qualifications to how that voice should
be spoken in order to do that in order
to have a society work like that the
needs to be within the people in that
society a certain openness to the other
so that for example
someone who is religious is not merely
not exclusivist towards those of other
religions but is actually prepared to
acknowledge that the secular can
sometimes have something to say to the
religious world but it also requires and
actually this is his often I think far
more resisted that those that are
secular should also realize that those
who are religiously inspired have
something to offer and to add to the the
the forum within which political debate
it is conducted so to summarize my my
views is is this that this is I think
there is a developing consensus that you
do require faith friendly democracy and
democracy friendly faith or a friendly
society society friendly faith the
question is how you achieve such a thing
and in order to achieve it you need a
combination of the right constitutional
framework the right policy and the right
attitude